تتواصل التظاهرات في اسرائيل ضد مشروع
حكومي لتعديل النظام القضائي ونتابع هذه
الصور المباشره من اسرائيل للتظاهرات في
اكثر من منطقه ومن بينها تل ابيب حيث
احتشد الاف الاسرائيليين قبل اسبوع مهم من
المتوقع ان يشهد ايضا المزيد من الخطوات
التشريعيه والاحتجاجات احدث هذه التظاهرات
ضربت المركز التجاري لاسرائيل بعد ايام من
تعهد رئيس الوزراء بنيام نتنياهو بانه
سيمضي قدما في هذه التغييرات على الرغم من
القلق الدولي المتزايد وايضا الداخلي
ونشاهد احتدام هذه التظاهرات في اسرائيل
على وقع هذه التعديلات القضائيه التي يصر
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي على تمري رها رغم
حاله الانقسام الشديد التي تسببت فيها
داخل اسرائيل وايضا داخل الائتلاف الحكومي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]